anyway I'm sorry I didn't I don't know
why I'm crying maybe I'm just gonna get
my period who knows Kelly Ripa got a
little choked up during Wednesday's
episode of live with Kelly and Ryan look
I'm not gonna lie okay I'm gonna let I'm
gonna let you in on a little secret I'm
currently not speaking to two of my
three kids right now
okay I'm not not talking to two of them
because just because we're all in the
same boat together right like I I
haven't gotten to hug my parent the
emotional moment went down during a chat
with her co-host Ryan Seacrest the two
are continuing to tape their show while
they are quarantined in their own homes
as for Kelly who shares three children
with her hubby Mark Consuelos well she
says her kids won't hug her and she just
misses her mom and dad I miss hugging my
parents and my kids like won't hug me
don't they're like I'm like guys we've
all been in lockdown together we're
we're fine you can give me a huh it's
fine that's when Kelly got all kinds of
teary eyed and let me just say it's
freaking relatable anyway I'm sorry I
didn't I don't know why I'm crying maybe
I'm just gonna get my period who knows
sorry sorry did I stop that
or was that my dig my inner monologue
come out sorry earlier in the show Kelly
and Ryan talked about how the New York
State Education Department canceled the
June 2020 Regents exams due to the
corona virus pandemic it's so funny
because my youngest Joaquin is so he's
so different than my other two kids who
would have been dancing in it just
dancing around the house they would have
been so excited but he has like this
level of anxiety from it he's really you
know he he felt so prepared but Joaquin
isn't the only family member on her mind
Kelly also opened up about her 20
year-old son Michael I feel so bad for
my son Michael who is was supposed to
graduate in a couple of weeks and I
really feel bad for my dad who delayed
having knee surgery that he can't
obviously have now for so many myriad
reasons but he was so looking forward to
you know watching his grandson graduate
from college it was such a big talking
point in our house and you know because
he not only is their graduation a it was
at Yankee Stadium but then he's film
school they have a separate graduation
and that was supposed to be at Radio
City and again these are small problems
considering that so many people are
losing their loved ones and very very
sick but it's just it is what it is you
know what I mean it's like Michael by
the way is not bothered
that's when Brian swooped in with a
pretty sweet backup plan a week not that
it's any substitute but perhaps we can
conduct a mini ceremony or him here
maybe yeah maybe I mean that would be
nice that would be one way to handle it
these two really are the cutest co-hosts
in daytime TV
of course ryan joined kelly in 2017 at
the time he told a tee that kelly is
magic we've known each other a long time
i think that every day that i see her
she i will text her sometimes you know
how great she is and that I'm in awe of
what she can do and I don't know if it's
appreciated what a skill it is to do
this show and be a friend to strangers
every day on television and so she
impresses me with her ability to do that
and with kindness every day I mean I'm
like I'm gonna cry I'm about to cry
I've worked with a lot of people and she
just has that magic
you